I did Alec dude who is suspected of
being the author all this hair attack
has been arrested and identified cute
jean da movie resources troops have been
deployed in the region the cv the plants
have been protected provided with
further protection and all measures are
being taken to prevent any other tragedy
and in order to prevent any other action
the Minister of the Interior will speak
immediately after i did in order to
provide useful information but nothing
more than useful information given that
there is an ongoing investigation which
is in the hands of the anti-terrorist
unit of the public prosecutor in this
circumstance is first of all our
thoughts go to the victim it is a matter
of solidarity of course that you won't
be induced to madtown the european
council this morning also expressed in
solidarity we all remember and have in
mind what happened in our country and in
other countries as well there is
therefore a lot of emotion but emotion
cannot be the only answer it is action
prevention deterrence and therefore the
necessity to support the despread our
values and never give in to fear to
shorter or responsibilities in all
possible circumstances it is not about
spreading any intolerable suspicions but
is about doing our job as is expected by
the French people it is about protecting
our people while finding out the truth
identifying the groups and the
individuals responsible for such actions
dude we're believing the european
council after talking to you as i told
my colleagues then i will be holding a
meeting at the elysee palace at
three-thirty will by then have some
further information and we'll take if
necessary some additional measures
lastly as I said the suspect has been
arrested and identified the
investigation is ongoing and I leave it
to the authorities in charge to provide
some extra information even though of
course as you understand we have to be
quite enough to make sure that the work
of our services is efficient thank you
for your understanding